le choix de 2,7 ce soir je crois qu'on
va faire l'heure du souper dans la
famille roy c'est toujours un peu un
casse tête
on n'est pas des folies on se sont
s'accommode très habillée d'une omelette
bassin on aime s'habiller manger votre
long on a essayé sur l'essai en question
c'est le prête à cuisiner cette botte
coquette a changé notre vie depuis 2014
les entreprises de prêts à cuisiner
multiplient les offres et les publicités
pour attirer les clients
le concept est simple des recettes à
suivre avec des ingrédients portionné le
tout livré chez dieu sait qu'on a une
équipe de deux personnes qui marchent et
good food est une de ces entreprises
montréalaises qui à la base souhaitait
réduire le gaspillage alimentaire
il ya près d'un tiers de l'épicerie
chaque semaine qu'on achète en moyenne
qui se retrouvent aux poubelles
donc avec le marché du cloud ou
n'importe quel service de prêt à
cuisiner qu'on planifie bien nos
semaines ça nous permet d'éliminer le
gaspillage
mais l'effet pervers c'est l'utilisation
massive du plastique
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a poussé
françois roy à limiter son utilisation
du service ça allait plus avec nous on
trouvait qu'il y avait il y avait
beaucoup d'emballages
même si la plupart de l'emballage est
recyclable pour johanne turbide
la solution devrait passer par le
compost et l'aide gouvernementale
on parle beaucoup en ce moment du fonds
ouverts il faut absolument qu'on aide
les entreprises à modifier leur chaîne
de valeur donc existe des emballages qui
sont faits en maïs pour pour la
nourriture et ça je pense que c'est des
initiatives sont qui sont très très
intéressante et très prometteuse en même
temps qu'ils paient pour ça bien
consciente de la critique marché good
food a investi 500 mille dollars dans le
développement d'un tel emballages
nouvelles tendances nouveau débat qui
rappelle celui des dosettes de café
les capsules de café le dr était bonne
aussi à la base c'est à dire on consomme
moins de grains de café à la source est
une ressource qui n'est pas inépuisable
mais on s'est rendu compte en bout de
ligne que les déchets avec les capsules
c'est devenu des montagnes de déchets
qui n'étaient pas aussi clairement
malgré la popularité du service
plusieurs clients se désabonnent après
quelques essais seulement signe que
c'est l'industrie veut perdurer elle
devra s'adapter à une clientèle de plus
en plus exigeante et soucieuse de
l'environnement
et si jacques andré charbonneau radio
canada montréal